welcome back to New Rockstars it's me
Tommy B and I'm happy to be back with
all my Wookie freaks talking about clone
Force 99 that's right it's a bad boy
breaking down bad batch baby in episode
11 metamorphosis felt like Halloween
came just a bit early with some serious
horror movie Vibes including visual
references to another iconic space-based
franchise alien we also got to see one
of the most terrifying animated
creatures I've ever seen and I went to
see both Smurf reboots okay so I know
now before we get started if you want to
look like me fresh to death with these
threads you need to visit nerd riot.shop
where we have a brand new line of
Mandalorian merch including our two
latest Obsession shirts the foundling
and the way now when you purchase these
shirts you have the option to get a
custom shout out from me or Eric Voss on
one episode of WikiLeaks which is now
taking place on the break room on
Wednesdays so you want me to tell your
girlfriend to get lost or your boyfriend
that you want to move in with him your
mother-in-law that she's got to move out
of the grandma unit buy a t-shirt get a
shout out and I'll do it that's at nerd
Rye it dot shot let's get into it we get
a great cold open of a badly damaged
transport ship coming out of hyperspeed
as the ship careens towards the planet a
clone Commando nervously searches for
his fellow clones while strange noises
Echo around him
he looks left he looks right but we all
know death comes from Above This is a
visual parallel to those great xenomorph
attack scenes in the alien movies I was
surprised to see a bad batch episode
open so terrifyingly even Kevin keiner's
score is Goosebump inducing
we get a last room exciting as the
nefarious Dr Hemlock antagonizes nalisay
on the mount Tanta station I believe
this location is another nod to alien as
the mount Tanta station is on the planet
Whalen Weyland yutani is the name of the
fiction Omega Corporation in the alien
movies Dr Hemlock is the newest
mechanically modified master of
malfeasance and he is none too pleased
that now let's say won't play ball and
help the emperor Nala who helped Omega
in the bad batch escaped Camino last
season seems to think the Empire wiping
her people off the map as a deal breaker
hard to disagree with that as far as we
know the only other kamino and that
survived the attack into poker city is
the prime minister who is currently
being held in a Cell in Coruscant Dr
Hemlock demands that the Prime Minister
be brought to Tantus for questioning
meanwhile the relationship between Sid
and the bad batch is growing further
strain even the normally cheerful Omega
seems to be growing tired of Sid's loose
interpretation of the words business
associates Sid says focus on the money
and tells them about transport 904 which
is the ship from the opening and how
it's ripe for pillaging Sid does a
terrible job negotiating the bad batches
percentage but it makes me think she was
purposely giving more up because she
assumed they weren't going to make it
again Sid's turn on the bad batch has
been teased all season this time she's
just limiting Intel to that we are back
in horror movie mode as the bad batch
reaches the wrecked transporter wrecker
finds an abandoned High volt electrostep
usually used by clone commandos and the
bane of my existence when playing Jedi
fall in order Tech resolves to restore
power to the ship and break away from
the rest of the group basically this is
shattering horror movie rule number one
don't split up you idiots Omega is very
worried about this idea but Tech insists
there is no reason to be concerned once
again these two are in on strategically
now many of you reached out to me last
week about how the show heavily implies
the tech is neurodivergent and possibly
on the Spectrum we don't have an answer
for that right now so until someone on
the creative side confirms it I'm not
100 comfortable talking about it but I
think it's really cool the show is
showcasing how everybody's brain works a
little bit differently naturally
splitting up proves to put both groups
in danger we've got tons of horror movie
setups scary music slime cliche lines
like this what were they keeping in here
I don't know if you see me walking
around with a little extra spring in my
step this week it's because our newest
designs just dropped over at
nerdriot.shop and they're for the
upcoming Mandalorian season three we got
two shirt designs one with grogu's
lovable head and one with din Jones
metallic mug I think they're both cute
and you can make them kiss both designs
have arabesh wording that translates to
the foundling and the way respectively
in a style that's inspired by beskar
Steel I'm inspired by best car still
every day when you buy one of these
shirts you get the option to buy a
special shout out on our Wikileaks after
show Once the series starts in March I
wish your girlfriend a happy birthday or
Eric Voss can say a prayer for the
foundlings that didn't make it through
the struggle whatever you want also at
nerdriot.shop our quantumania line of
shirts and hoodies are on sale
everything is 15 off until the end of
February get the new Mando designs and
all of our other merch offerings at
nerdriot.shop do it like all good scary
movies The Monsters Finally Revealed
halfway through and holy [__] the Zillow
Beast is terrifying this monster feeds
on electricity much like the megavolt
monster in Godzilla the electricity it
consumes makes it grow Zillow Beast made
several appearances in the Clone Wars
and it's one of good old Chief
Palpatine's secret weapons to
controlling the Galaxy also I forgot to
mention this thing was eating a clone
Commando when we saw it the creature is
now running loose on the planet the ship
crashed on and growing in size with each
high voltage bite Omega is able to
identify a lot of the tech on board the
ship as kamino and cloning Tech but
thinks that this creature was created
off world the ramifications of the
attack on topoka City have been Rippling
below the surface All Season it feels
like they're about to reach a boiling
point suspiciously good timing on the
Empire's part leads to this cool King
Kong tribute with Imperial ships
blasting the monster off the side of the
building it was scaling before taking a
prisoner the bad batch narrowly escapes
and I swear to God if they work with Sid
again they're going to get a Stern
talking to you from the T-man seriously
everything seemed set up for the bad
bash to get captured and I suspect Sid
was behind it Hunter agrees with me
which is why he's sending all of text
findings from the downship to Captain
Rex and Echo the citizens of this world
are taking into custody by the Empire Dr
Hemlock implies they're going to be
dealt with which in Star Wars speak
means killed so what we know is that the
emperor is cloning zilobis and hoping to
weaponize them the former prime minister
of kamino tells Dr Hemlock that he must
capture Omega if he wants Nala say to
cooperate with the emperor's plans I
think the search for Omega will probably
occupy a lot of our final five episodes
and that's about all the time I have to
occupy this episode and I'm Gonna Leave
it right there we'll be back next week
with our episode 12 Easter egg breakdown
I'm Tommy Bechtel follow me at Tommy
Bechtel follow new rockstars on all
platforms don't forget to pick up our
sweet sweet merch at nerdriot.shop and I
will see you later for now
I have spoken
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]